moment alter das ich mich gerade richtig
krank ich sage dir wie ich finde dass
das schmeckt ich finde das schmeckt wie
arizona juli herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen video leute ich habe heute
etwas vorbereitet und zwar habe ich
letztens bei guten medical morning das
ist eine youtube webserie aus amerika
den titel und das thumbnail von dem
video gesehen ich habe nicht angeguckt
weil ich mir selbst nichts bauen wollte
und zwar wollten sie testen was passiert
wenn man cola in den wasserfilter
schüttet und ihr kennt mich ich mache
gerne also experiment deshalb habe ich
das hier unten vorbereitet ich habe eine
cola eine fanta eine flasche powerade
einen handelsüblichen wasserfilter und
zwei gläser dass man es immer gegenüber
stellen kann
das ist was wir heute machen wir testen
schmeckt es anders sieht es anders aus
habe extra noch mal so ein ersatz filter
gekommen dass ich überprüfen kann ob wir
auch die optimale effekte haben und was
man zu sebastian hinter der kamera
was meinst du was für ein machen ich
würde sagen wir fangen an mit fanta ich
will sagen fand wir haben eine ganz
unterschiedliche charakteristiken so
kohler ist fast schwarz und kannst nicht
durch oder durch kannst du dich konnte
durch schon
ja natürlich meine meine brüder aufwand
da muss man sagen freunde der werte team
bringt wird man die auf wir testen das
ganze jetzt aus ich mach die kasse auf
und gehe ich bin gespannt wie schnell
läuft ist dadurch müssen natürlich
darauf machen braucht ja gemacht aber
der kurze frage weiter machen dafür
justins probieren davon
er guckt ihn also so komisch an der
praktiker ist glaube dass trotzdem sagt
lassen
legt sich einfach nicht von wasser peter
gelegen 321 man kann es einfach rein
schütten
es fließt kann ich durch nicht oder doch
dann kommt etwas was traut und gott dass
ich übertrieben klar aus ist guckst du
ob der fakt dass sie das was da
rauskommt oder vielleicht auch nur weil
so wenig ist aber wenn du die farben
vergleicht oder warte mal machen
doch das ist noch das ist auf jeden fall
noch leicht geld jetzt ist es noch ich
dachte wir gehen einfach klare fand
daher stellen ein bisschen geld ist es
aber es ist deutlich weniger geld oder
was würde passieren wenn wir klare kante
für junge ohne scheiß ich bin richtig
gespannt und daneben ein bisschen über
dieses video der geredet wie das
schmeckt also auch geschmacksstoffe
rausgefiltert werden auf jeden fall so
ist es schmeckt es dann der
zitronengeschmack raus vielleicht ist es
einfach die gesunde alternative zu fand
werden alle öko mütter in zukunft die
vater ihrer kinder filtern lassen wenn
eine kuh mutter seite dass sie irgendwie
skeptisch hinaus aber war kurz und die
farbe ist auf jeden fall eine andere
würde ich muss überlegen da steht ja
noch auch im gräflichen untergrund lebt
mal hoch es ist schon eine andere ein
bisschen anders sieht das oben ist
gelber das bisschen grüner aus und vor
allem man sieht kein bisschen mehr von
der kohlensäure keine konserve madrid
scheint so zu sein
probieren wir gleich mal leute werden
diese fand jetzt fehlt er vollständig
einfach mal bei euch bedanken dass sie
so zahlreich immer meine videos
einschaltet ihr müsst ihr euch
vorstellen ich war lange zeit nicht
wirklich aktiv ab drei monate lang fast
nicht hob dann komm zurück und hat auch
bei so vielen videos so viel
unterstützung und support erfahren dafür
wollte mich noch mal bedanken wenn ihr
auch teil der kran fan der power kids
der kranfahrer familie sein wollt da
abonniert gerne unten und mit ihr mehr
von solchen verrückten videos sehen
okay man muss sagen die farbe hat sich
jetzt wieder bisschen reguliert mehr ist
es mehr okay am anfang sehr deutlich aus
dem direkten vergleich
ja sie kann aber da mal testen wie oft
man cola filtern muss damit sie klar
wird vielleicht wobei wahrscheinlich
sind es dann irgendwie so 24 tage durch
filter also häufig sei so durch 1000
schichten lokal ich sage es okay so
leute das hier ist ihr gefehlt hatte
fand sie sieht jetzt eigentlich keiner
ist durch glaubt ist schon wieder
relativ normal aus die hat sie auch
gesehen im ersten moment saß einfach
über gras ausgeschöpft jetzt als erstes
mal ein normales glas fand hier ein job
gehört auch hin
man hört ganz klassisch ist sprudelt
buskies das und das hier ist jetzt die
gefilterte fand das klingt viel wasser
ohne kohlensäure
es ist jetzt eigentlich wasser weil es
bei den wasserfilter besteht aus fanta
wasser okay leute hier haben wir die
gegenüberstellung ok mal ganz klar links
auf jeden fall noch kurse drin recht ist
alles raus andere farblich es ist
ähnlich hat es ihr mal nichts getan aber
als nächstes will ich sagen probieren
wir mal erst mal die klassische fand
aber würde ich sagen dass ich den
vergleich habe okay du hast noch nicht
also da aber kein scheiß [ __ ] ich finde
wirklich was okay das ist die noch mal
an einem original gefiltert ich mal dran
okay man auf jeden fall so einer orangen
note das ist wirklich kein scheiß marica
klinik mehr orten dieser orden geruch
des komplett weg leute da ist es so weit
ich probiere jetzt die gefilterte fand
ob sie irgendwie anders schmeckt das ist
so verrückt es ist dass er sehr viel
probiert hast zu beschreiben
ich finde das schmeckt einfach mit
wasser gemischt da rosa wirklich wahr so
ist rosa orangensaftkonzentrat aber
irgendwie das ist verrückt probiert muss
mal findet das schmeckt nicht mehr die
fanta also das blind im sagen uns dass
orange sachen keine fand aber leider
sich farblich nichts getan
die farbe ist gleich die farbe ist
gleich der piccolo effekt wäre es
natürlich gewesen wenn das jetzt
komplett farblos rausgekommen wäre so
jetzt bin ich gespannt alter verrückt
oder orangensaft einfach aber voll
der fehltritt wird ja ja ich habe auch
das gefühl gehabt dass es irgendwie
sowie eine light-version schmeckt so
fand alheit ohne kurve also ich finde
party haben sich verändern erst mal du
hast nicht mehr so diesen diese frucht
säure drin
die anomale hast du ja cool sei
natürlich nicht drin und deutlich
weniger säurehaltige und schmeckt als
weniger zucker irgendwie so leute
nächster versuch parat steht bereit
ich fange jetzt aber entsteht dann noch
eine neue firma kathrein und vielleicht
mit der effekt dann auch besser mehr
farbe aus klavier gespannt weil beim
letzten mal weil die größte veränderung
die kohlensäure und daher hinter
geschmack weil die kurse aber
geschmackvoll und jetzt wäre wirklich
schauen was sich genau an geschmack hat
ja was fließt gerade das aber umso
interessanter wird schmeckt es anders
wird es weniger blau sein bin ich jemand
der jedes mal die gleiche frage steht
ich bin voll krass wie der geschmack
nicht der geschmack der geruch von dem
getränk sich sofort im ganzen darauf
erhalten dass man die welt getrunken
das wollen wir sie noch macht geht dann
ja kommen auch noch mal durch einmal auf
so schnell kann man nochmal und nochmal
der direkte vergleich parat versus
filter rage ok also ist eindeutigen
unterschied sich deutlich hätte direkt
links ist so hellblau und rechts er so
türkis
ok jetzt geschmackstest normale paare
schmeckt irgendwie normale porridge die
andere gefehlt hat war erstmal geruch
ganz normal ist es wieder genau das
gleiche ding der größe genau das gleiche
schnell der schnelltest sagt einfach nur
videos öffnet auch das original ja keine
ruf wieder kein großer informiert ist
die gefühlte der parade vor diesen
bitterer geworden und die paul ray hat
schon so ein leicht bitteren geschmack
die ist echt bitter geworden
das ist einfach eigenartig probieren die
sind halt eigentlich war das irgendwie
schön so wir haben das längst normalität
dass du denn geschmack im kopf hast
schmeckt schon leicht bitter finde ich
nachher nach der fantast sondern leicht
saure note irgendwie ne jetzt muss ich
abbrechen und das gefälle riecht wie
danach nichts und es schmeckt einfach
irgendwie sozusagen wollen oder was
schmeckt wie während die sich vergessen
und die zähne zu putzen und dann zu
lange geschlafen hat und wenn man dann
auf 8 sowie sohn geschmack hat man den
hund finde ich mich freue mich es ist
einfach nur teure es überhaupt keinen
geschmack mehr drin also sauer und ganz
kleines bisschen süße mehr sauer süß und
ich auch leute kommen jetzt schon wohl
interessantesten teil des videos coca
cola steht bereit passat peter steht
bereit reden wir nicht lange drumherum
für uns einfach ein cooler ist drin
jetzt heißt es warten
es läuft genauso durch wie die panther
wahrscheinlich keine kohlensäure drin
ist muss erstmal rausgefiltert werden
dass sie wieder so gut aus von oben
bietet der blog dealing konzept ist
vorreiter leute für den optimalen effekt
werden wir das jetzt aber vielleicht ein
zweimal mehr fehlt dann einfach damit
besonders cool aussieht so läuft
fünf mal gefehlt hatte kuka sieht so aus
scheint sehen nicht so super viel
getanzt oder müssen noch beide seiten
erst mal normale bruder ein schuppen und
die geteco das ist so komisch diese
ganzen getränke und größe des kindes
fast genau gleich genau gleich
bürgerfreundlich also man sieht bei der
einst kohl hat noch blasen drin waren
andere nicht okay textastic oder
schmeckt mir normale bruder
moment mal und jetzt der test mit der
gefehlt auf dem col
wobei oder da sind wir noch mal richtig
nicht gar nichts ich probiere moment
alter das finde ich gerade richtig krank
ich sag dir wie ich finde dass das
schmeckt ich finde das schmeckt wie
arizona blut also wie der arizona heißt
dpa ist die sache einfach kopiert oslo
bekannt seien erst mal normale coca cola
hat konnte gefehlt hatte
jetzt probieren und sag mal findet das
haus wie arizona blau.de schmeckt es
wirklich sucht oder will ich wirklich
das ist was seine letzte ahnung von
kohlensäure deswegen schmeckt es vom
gefühl her ein bisschen anders aber man
konnte ich mal das im glauben ist ich
finde auch ich finde das schmeckt wie
der erotische oder blau wäre weil er
auch so diese leichte säure darin noch
das ist total kraft also der zucker
schmeckt ja ja wir auch probieren
normale cola kennst und probiere einfach
nur die gefehlt haben sagt auch darauf
hin dass das wieder blaue jetzt nicht
mehr erst mal die echte cola cola light
und danach die gebildete und im direkten
vergleich mit meinen ängsten
klassenunterschied wurde schmeckte das
eis schmeckt echt nich also leute man
kann sagen wenn ihr gerade
experimentiert aus die ich seit nichts
zu tun haben und vielleicht sonntags zu
hause sitzt fragt ob ihr eure
wasserfilter wahrscheinlich kaputt
machen dürft macht das ganze selbst
schmeckt wirklich alles anders fand sehr
interessant gerade jetzt bei cola für
mich einfach komplett ungarn ist es nach
blaubär schmeckt also ich finde es
persönlich sebastian auch leute das
war's vom heutigen video last gern ein
like da wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder und bis dahin tschüss